Baron Jay, actor/producer: We met about 6
years ago and we kind of like reconnected
through our mutual Detroit Farmer maybe like
three or four years ago.
So it’s been a great ride.
Michael Joseph, actor/producer: Great ride.
He’s calling us to set.
Joe Bohn, first AD: I do have to hold for
these guys.
I love your BTS but I’ve got a picture to
make.
Alright, let’s go guys.
Michael Joseph: Thank you guys.
Joe Bohn: My name is Joe Bohn.
I’m the first assistant director on DEADLY
REUNION.
[Joe on set directing actors and crew]
“She’ll be on your right.
Monica will be on your left.
So Monica let’s actually start you here.
We’ll actually start you ahead.
I know that’s not how you actually did it
before but we’ll start you ahead just for
safety sake in doing this.
So real hand speed here’s the action.
We walk in…you’re with them, you’re
with them.
And then Chuckie will come into here.
So let’s just pick it up from right there
guys.
We get clustery in that top end.
So Chuckie this is your one, Stu let’s have
you Chuckie’s on the right.
Jill let’s have you on the left (this is
where you’re going to end up).
I want to clean this up a little bit.
Stu you are on the right of the camera…there
we go.
So we start going through the stuff like you
guys do, so let’s start going through the
stuff.
Film Courage: How did you get attached to
the project, Joe?
Joe Bahn: Joe Karam who is one of the actors
(he plays Bobby) he was in negotiations to
come onto the project and we worked together
once before and he wanted to make sure that
if he was going to be a part of it he wanted
it to be ran really well from an on set perspective
and made one of his conditions that I be hired
on as well before he would accept his involvement
so that’s how I got on.
[Joe on set]
“Here we go!
Quiet all around please.
Picture’s up.
Slated and roll sound.”
“Sound speed”
“Call it”
“18 Apple - Take 2”
“Camera”
“Mark”
“Let me know”
Film Courage: And how long have you been first
ADing?
Joe Bohn: Professionally first AD…a little
over 5 years?
I moved out from San Francisco (I got my Master’s
up there) and one of my associates moved down
here as well booked a first AD job for Miley
Cyrus for one of her videos.
He brought me on as a second AD.
The producers liked him (but they didn’t
want to bring him back) so they brought me
back instead and they started bringing me
back over and over again, recommending me
to other producers and that’s kind of the
history of everything, that’s the history
of my career.
I just got recommended and just kind of spider-webbed
out from there.
Film Courage: And as a first AD what is your…from
the minute you get on set, what is your responsibility?
What are you looking for at all time?
Joe Bohn: No dead time.
I mean fundamentally you are trying to get
the greatest amount of quality footage in
the can for the director and the production
at any given time.
And what usually happens on a lot of sets
(especially if you don’t have a strong first)
is that downtime where people are ready to
work but no one is telling them to work, no
one is telling them to go there and do that.
It almost in some ways feels like babysitting…I
don’t want to put down other departments,
it’s not like that.
But people are waiting to do their jobs you
don’t have a foreman (like on a construction
site) waiting to tell them “Okay guys, you
need to go in and do this.
You need to come out so they can go in and
do this,” then no one knows what to do and
it’s a lot of people milling around.
So for me as soon as we’re in, as soon as
that clock hits 7 o’clock, 8’ o’clock
(whatever time your call time is) it is immediately
getting every department working on something.
An ideal schedule or an ideal world or an
ideal world has every department constantly
working on something whether it’s the scene
that we’re shooting currently, prepping
the next scene, wrapping out the previous
scene, any elements like that, that we can
do.
We have a B camera that’s not shooting because
of the set-up in this particular scene, then
let’s get the B camera to go outside and
get B roll.
Let’s get the house, let’s get the cars,
let’s get the sunset, let’s get something.
But if people are sitting around doing nothing,
then that becomes an issue that should be
rectified in an ideal world.
Watch your ears real quick [Joe prepares crew
and actors for upcoming scene] “Nine minutes
guys!
Nine minute warning.”
[Joe back on set preparing crew and actors]
“Here we go!”
“Are we coming in on this one?”
“Yeah, I’ll try to call it.”
“So this isn’t afterward…this is…”
“Pictures up.
Quiet all around.
“From the top, let’s continue to do it.
We’re going to try some new semantics.
Slated!
Roll sound.”
“Rolling.
Call it.”
“Sound speed.”
“Scene 21 Apple - Take 1.”
“Camera.
Camera.”
“Speed.”
“Mark it.”
Film Courage: So as a first AD you’re almost
never resting while on set?
It sounds like you’re always looking for
the next step and doing two things at once
it sounds like?
Joe Bohn: Yeah, as a first AD if you’re
resting, I’m not sure you are working?
I don’t know how that works?
Look on your bigger budget stuff where you
have a second AD, a second second, multiple
second seconds, key PA, PA.
When you have all these personnel and all
these resources at your disposal, sure you
can step off set and relax.
If you smoke, have a cigarette, whatever the
case may be.
But if you are working in the let’s say
under $250,000 budget range, you just don’t
have the personnel underneath you to support
you in that kind of way and in order to keep
the film moving at a pace that usually (again
at those budget levels) it needs to move,
you have to be “on” at all times.
You don’t step off set to 10:1 to use the
restroom.
You step off set to 10:1 to grab a bottle
of water and come back and theoretically if
you’ve got a PA, you radio them and they
get you the water.
Because every second that you step off is
a second that someone may not be working or
things may not be moving forward.
Those seconds add up over the course of a
day and certainly over the course of a long
shoot.
And what they add up to is shots you couldn’t
get, set-ups you couldn’t grab, performances
that couldn’t be tweaked because you didn’t
have time and that time gets lost…yes because
other people weren’t doing their jobs but
fundamentally you weren’t there to supervise
them and have them continue to work through
that.
[Joe back on set preparing crew and actors]
“Let me emphasize that, these are your marks,
right?
These are your marks.
Let’s not wander, let’s not waddle, let’s
stay where we are.
Harry is the only one who is going to pin
it to the stove to where he is.
Camera we’ve got sharps.”
Film Courage: Challenges for a first AD on
set and how you work around it?
Joe Bohn: Challenges for a first AD on set
and how you work around it?
Well, that’s the challenge in and of itself.
Each film set inherently comes with its own
variables and its own issues.
It would be very easy to be like “Oh, well
the problems are X, Y and Z and this is how
you solve them.
Unfortunately that’s not the situation.
Certainly in this industry but specifically
as a first AD.
You have to first and foremost evaluate what
your resources are and resources refer to
not only just what you psychically have but
your personnel as well.
Do I have five people or do I have one?
That’s going to change the problems you
are going encounter and how you can solve
them.
Ideally you are solving those problems before
you get to them anyways but maybe you’re
not.
And then obviously the psychical resources
of your equipment, money, the house, what
time can we shoot, fighting the daylight (if
you’re outside), that kind of stuff.
So in terms of common problems…I think really
the most common problem you are always going
to run into is personality.
You have people with egos or not with egos,
people that are hard to work with or easy
to work with, but they are green, they are
not experienced, they want to learn.
So you have to teach on set as you go along.
It’s really…fundamentally it’s not about
being the first AD that you think you should
be.
It’s about being the first AD that this
particular production, these particular people,
need you to be.
I think that’s the problem that a lot of
people who take this position is that they
come in…the know the rules, they know the
regulations, they know how to do the job,
but they approach every job the same.
And in doing so, you can’t fit a square
peg in a round hole.
You have to be malleable yourself and take
those first few days to figure out what this
needs and how to work with people.
And if you can do that and adapt quickly and
efficiently, then hopefully you minimize those
problems that you are talking about.
Film Courage: For you…when you first step
on [set]…let’s suppose you are going to
have a 17-day shoot at what point do you find…that
you get this gut-level “Okay…I think this
is where the issues are going to be.”
Not specific people (maybe, maybe not) but
where do you get the temperament of the set?
When does it start to reveal itself to you?
Joe Bohn: I think by Day 2.
I think if you are really paying attention
probably really (honestly) by lunch on Day
1.
Because it’s very easy to see “Okay, he’s
got a chip on his shoulder, he doesn’t communicate
well, and she’s…”
You can really kind of get that pretty quickly.
But if haven’t figured out by Day 2, then
you’re not going to figure it out (you’re
just not).
At that point it should have revealed itself.
Now in a 17-day shoot, if you’re moving
from a location-to-location maybe new problems
arise in that sense where you are in this
location but this location is super strict.
They want padding down on the floor, they
want layout board, ram board, and they want
this, that and the other.
So you have to discover those problems and
then change and acclimate to them extremely
fast because you don’t have the two days
previously to kind of build up to it and work
out a scheme or a plan to make it work.
So that’s the biggest thing.
Otherwise yeah…if you are paying attention
and you’re on set and you are working with
people and you are listening and communicating,
I think you find out by the end of the first
day, really.
No later than the end of the second.
Film Courage: I get the sense that you are
really good at reading people.
That you just have this innate thing where
you can figure what someone needs, where they
need to be lead, am I right with that?
You have a really quick sense with that?
Joe Bohn: Yeah, I think I do.
I think I have a really quick sense to read
people.
It makes me as valuable and as good at the
job as I am (I hope it does).
I think without that it becomes much more
difficult to do the job effectively as I want
to and I strive to do it.
[Joe back on set preparing crew and actors]
“Okay, let’s try one guys.
Obviously Chuck has total control here to
say Stop, Cut…whatever the case may be.
Let’s go to one.
Watch the lights, watch the reflections.”
“Are we going from one or are we going to…sorry
to cut you off.
Are we starting from one?”
“What?
Just starting from right here.
Guys, let me have you clear over from this
side just to be safe, then we don’t swing
and all over the world.”
“Does that include me?”
“No you are okay, Justin.
Thank you.
Okay, let’s try it.
Cameras going up, pictures going up.”
Film Courage: So we are on the set of DEADLY
REUNION and this is day eight of….?
Joe Bohn: Eight of eight is today for DEADLY
REUNION.
Film Courage: Eight of eight, okay.
And you have been in this one location.
What have been some of the challenges at this
location and how have you been working through
it?
And also the script changes?
Joe Bohn: Location is simple enough.
I mean it’s a dual coin, right?
You get challenges and benefits from being
in one location.
The benefits being no location moves, you
don’t have to wrap out which takes time
every time you do it, you’re taking time
away from shooting, time away from shooting.
Because we are living here, all the gear is
constant.
It’s very easy to come in at the top of
the day, have a 7:00 a.m. call, be shooting
by 8:00 because everything is here.
And if you end the previous day correctly
then you can already be lit, art decked and
pre-blocked for the following day.
So you come and you get right to work.
So that’s the benefits.
The problem is you are in one location for
a long time.
From an aesthetic point (directorially speaking),
aesthetically you don’t have a lot of variety
in your visual aesthetic, which can bore the
audience.
That’s the director in me talking but you
can get the idea.
From a practical standpoint as an AD, we are
really on top of each other.
There is gear here, you don’t have a lot
of room to maneuver (this isn’t a mansion,
it’s a house) to it’s very congested.
And it’s a matter of efficiently having
the departments work around each other.
So having grip and electric come in, having
them come out and then having art go in.
If everyone just tries to cluster and do their
jobs at the same time, you have a mess and
everything goes slower.
The way to do it efficiently is to make sure
that certain departments have the floor at
certain times to make it work in the quickest
way possible.
Now as for scheduling and the script changes,
so there is a Day 1 rewrite which is fine
if it’s a partial rewrite or a scene rewrite.
This is a full rewrite of the script during…that
was decided to be done on Day 1 of photography
(on day one of shooting).
So we shut down a half-day early, the rewrites
started.
So as an AD what becomes extremely problematic
and extremely challenging is how do I schedule
the rest of the shoot?
How do you schedule a film that you don’t
know what is about to take place?
Theoretically I would have a break down.
I would know everything that goes on in every
scene, I know what props I need, what wardrobe
changes, what special effects and I have everything
blocked out and certain ways to shoot it…again,
efficiently.
In this situation I didn’t have that.
So the beginning of production was challenging
and stressful I think for a lot of departments,
especially camera, grip and electric, in that
usually you’d shoot out all the scenes in
the living room and then all the scenes in
the bathroom and then you’d just be done
with that room and you’d move on.
Because we were getting pages the morning
of, we were pretty much shooting in chronological
order, just living room to bathroom, back
to living room, back to here…because I never
knew what was coming next.
I didn’t have time, the director didn’t
have time, no one really had time to break
things down and look at it, we just had to
grab them and go.
What the challenge there becomes is the morale,
that’s really the challenge.
Because no one really wants to go back…“We're
going back to the living room, again?
For the same lighting setting up that we just
had…Okay?”
And you can just feel that morale drown.
And once that starts to go down, you feel
the energy dip.
When the energy dips, people move slower.
Even if people are trying to do their jobs,
they just don’t have the passion for it.
So it’s really the passion of checking my
time, sorry [checks phone for when to be back
on set].
“Five minutes guys!
Five minute warning.”
[Addresses actors and crew]
So the passion dips and everything moves slower.
You don’t get as much footage in the can,
you don’t get as much quality out of your
personnel.
What was nice is that we had already scheduled
a three-day break in the middle of week 1
and week 2.
So during that three-day break, the screenwriter
who is doing the revisions was able to get
a good chunk of pages out.
Now that first week what I was doing was going
home, seeing what few pages I had (four or
five) and trying to plant some kind of game
plan whatever it might be and get something
out.
And that worked…to a level it worked…as
much as it could.
But now on the last day of that break I got
15-20 pages.
So there I could actually schedule a day or
two out and actually put some things together
and block shoot some scenes.
So that became much more accessible, much
more tackle-able?
Able to be tackled…(there you go)…much
more able to be tackled than it had previously,
which is where we are now at this point on
Day 8, the last three days we’ve been able
to run a more legitimately planned set (if
you will) than flying by the cuff of our pants
than we had.
Film Courage: And I understand some people,
actors or whomever are not aware of who is
dying, when and they may be surprised?
Joe Bohn: In the original script nobody really
died per se.
Characters may have left the scene for awhile.
For the most part, they all lived.
One character died toward the end but they
are all in it until the end but everyone is
really in the whole thing.
During that day one rewrite conversation,
it was decided that some of those characters
would die to up the drama and the tension.
In dining so everyone was like “Okay, yeah…we
are okay with that.”
I don’t think anyone thinks they are going
to be the first to die until they are and
then they are like “Ahhhh…I died on page
15?
I wanted to be in the movie.”
So that’s the situation, actors coming in
and looking over the pages in the morning
and “Holy!
This is what happens today?”
Or “I died today?”
Or whatever it may be.
And we were doing the same thing, as well.
Just reading it and going and going “Wow!
This is going to be a fun day.”
So yeah, they didn’t know it was coming.
The tough part about that is budgeting the
time and structuring and things like that
is usually I can look at something and say
“Okay this is a massive fight scene.”
And maybe it only says it’s 1/8th of a page
total on the script but I know it’s going
to be 4 hours of shooting to get it.
Without having the time to do that pre-production
work and really break down the script, I’m
left with guessing at how much time certain
things should take strictly based on my previous
experience.
Which has actually worked out pretty well
but also could have been a catastrophe.